[Music]
this song might be familiar to you
United States Canada Mexico Panama Haiti
Jamaica Peru
okay well listen to this the United
States Canada Mexico Panama Haiti
Jamaica Peru
Recovery's Dominican Cuba Carribean
Greenland El Salvador - where - Rico
Columbia Venezuela Honduras Guyana and
still Rob Paulsen
has a voice that helped define 90's
cartoons okay well let's see I'm Yakko
Warner hello nurse I'm also pinky from
pinky in the brain for those of you who
are fans of Jimmy Neutron I'm Carl I'm
the little fat guy and you did Raphael
from the original Ninja Turtles right
yeah Raphael sounds a lot like me yeah
say things like shredder you tin face
deep get back here and taste cold turtle
steel and all the voices they have a
background story let's go where did the
inspiration from pinky come from well
for me it was a large part of my deep
abiding love for British humour is a
future for you pinky knock Peter Sellers
was a huge inspiration but for some
reason mr. Spielberg and his infinite
wisdom decided it was a good fit with
maurice lamarche who was the brain so
here we are
wait Steven Spielberg oh my god there he
is he produced pinky in the brain and
Animaniacs we will wait and he did
Saving Private Ryan twister men and
black and Schindler's List while he was
making these cartoons okay
[Music]
IMDB side check over sorry back to rob
okay great
okay so Yakko from Animaniacs where did
his voice come from only our hairdresser
knows for sure they decided on this
little sort of helium based voice that
kind of a smartass vibe a la Groucho
Marx hey Batman does Dracula know you're
wearing his cape so badly and as for the
song where he sings every country in the
world the interesting thing is it only
took me one take to record it the song
is a beautifully crafted piece that's
the difficult part not singing you can
hear him we're in goof troop Darkwing
Duck gummy bears Tiny Toon Adventures
the list goes on this guy's kind of
legend I don't write them and I don't
draw them I'm just a singer but it is
cool thing to be associated with those
shows it's pretty cool nobody cares what
I look like so I can do it as long as I
can breathe
[Music]
the Mortal Kombat games are some of the
most iconic of all time round one flight
and when you're winning nothing is
sweeter than hearing these words
sucia but what man could be so even
suited to channel such a demonic voice
feel the power of my name is Steve
Ritchie and I'm a pinball and video game
designer in the early 90s Steve was
making pinball machines in the very same
building a couple of guys were
developing the second Mortal Kombat game
upstairs was pinball down stair video
development Steve did the voices for a
bunch of pinball machines he designed
most of the time I do I do bad guys and
this is the voice that I have and it can
be I am the black difficult ac/dc a
devil I'm on the highway to hell so when
the Mortal Kombat creator needed a new
voice for the announcer he knew what
right where to go and pulled Steve into
the recording booth and he started
telling me say it like this
fatality you would say no more breathy
lower ecology Paul this BP that little R
had to be wrong lately okay round one
white oh that was it oh you have to add
the effects you know lower pitch fiducia
well cool okay Johnny Cage wins mortal
kombat has spawned a dozen video games
comic books TV shows and a film
franchise featuring this awesome techno
song
but Steve's contribution to Mortal
Kombat isn't what he's known for its
pinball because Steve he's made a lot of
pinball machines I've created more
pinball machines than anyone else in the
pinball history well whether he's a
voice in a video game or designing a
pinball machine
the thing Steve loves most well we'll
let him tell you I like to put the
player in a spot of an adversarial
relationship a battle you're beating
your ball snatching it into things to
experience Mortal Kombat you know it's a
video game but when he says something
it's like round one fight it's just like
he's scary and and you are battling this
guy hey Steve hey Jim just kidding you
should do it Steve finishing this one
quiet
[Music]
villains from 80s cartoons had a similar
sound and there was a reason for that
most were voiced by this guy what Alan
Oppenheimer my name is Alan Oppenheimer
and I'm an actor most famously he's the
voice of Falkor from neverending story
and Skeletor from he-man why are you
asking me these stupid questions got a
life regarding he-man Masters of the
Universe
I was Skeletor I figured the voice would
reverberate inside that bony head so
that's why he went up in here nice aw
you boob you idiot why are you bothering
living you've got a better life
somewhere else get out of my face he did
some other villainous voices there does
seem to be some relation there I stole
for myself I mean hey if I plagiarize
myself you know don't pursue me you know
come in yo Rio bub but then there was
falcore falcore was the luckdragon
he's kind and he's big and fuzzy my name
is Falco and he's flying so you have
that feel whoa let's go a trail
see and he actually did a few other
characters from neverending story
very tasty mmm get the picture
Alan's had an amazing career for me
though I like Falkor Alan will you do
the voice again
betrayal get on my back and we'll fly oh
there are those bullies
let's get them okay yes
[Music]
tell me if this voice sounds familiar
sweetly um of soil what about this one
in brightest day in blackest night okay
you definitely know this 150 years have
passed we could easily keep going
through his 300 other characters but
let's just cut to the chase and meet the
man behind the voice this is Phil Lamarr
and he's a voice actor I'd say the ones
that I'm probably best known for hoodies
Code Red certified bureaucrat from the
show Futurama Berta Virgil Hawkins aka
static shot from the static shot John
Smith reruns of Justice thing where the
man from Family Guy Holly Williams has
the story
Molly I'm at the wrong Airport oops well
thanks Eileen wilt can Foster's Home for
Imaginary Friends one of my favorites is
Dracula from grim adventures of Billy
and Mandy and of course the Senate I
know as Jack from the cities of the same
name he who wears a mask cannot see what
lies within himself when I was working
on pulp fiction wait you were in pulp
fiction
of course yeah here let me jog your
memory Marvin Bobby I've not dead [ __ ]
off
oh you're Marvin and I was one of the
original cast members on Fox's MADtv no
way I loved MADtv and you must have been
a fourteen-year-old boy in the nineties
very funny Phil anyway you were saying
with Samurai Jack I felt there should be
some tie to his roots so it was a very
light Japanese accent on English we
again to be referred to as a young Asian
Clint Eastwood voice and Hermes from
Futurama where did that voice come from
when I first started out doing did you
make an accent for Hermes he was pretty
much a heavy pot well and it it muddied
up the comedy so eventually your homies
accent got pulled back which is a lot
easier to understand
we're not Jon Stewart from Justice
League to me if you've got a chest this
big you gotta have a deep voice my name
is Jon Stewart
Green Lantern of sector to eight one
four and how about static shock that
voice was basically just myself at 14 it
was just that idea of you know a young
kid you know who's a responsible guy but
you know he just happens to have
electrical powers and to me that is the
character I relate to the most
you know static is just you know me the
differences between stage film
voice acting a really technical fat
plain leaves are no not on a drug and I
regretted one of the benefits we have
animation is I can play this guy and I
can also play this guy you'll see what
I'm talking about just right there in
the same day same room same microphone
you know cuz that's why we got into this
play characters you will bow before the
column
[Music]
all right Tara in this one rocky said a
mountaintop he gets swatted by the
monster tail he falls tumbles and rolls
and pulls up another ledge falls another
bunch of budgeted feet and then crashes
alright watch my hands i watch you here
comes the perfect my name is tara strong
and I'm mostly known for my animation
career I'm the voice of Timmy Turner
from The Fairly OddParents Raven from
Teen Titans Azarath metrion zinthos
originally I was Batgirl alongside Mark
Hamill and Kevin Conroy I've had a
really fun career and that was one tough
montage so I knew to me had to be happy
mischievous silly kinda nerdy
oh it's very very adventurous bubbles
had this weird way of pronouncing things
like Oh like I don't know why it goes
Elly like that but yeah the timeline
booked Rugrats I just got off a plane of
the screaming baby and I'm like that's
the cry that I'm doing and most of
Dill's lines were in the stage
directions so I'd be like okay
and I was like my lines I remember at
the session we had to stop tape and I'm
thinking something's wrong and they said
Terra there's a new mom in the studio
and you're making her lactate and you
guys say I'm not funny but seriously
this will be extremely painful in the
case of Raven while I was doing the
audition it was similar to my own voice
and I thought just this idea dava's
weird got a little role every time she
says anything as soon as I started doing
this I saw all the people in the booth
kind of look at each other and went
that's Raven Robin stop Batgirl was me
like it's the only voice I do that's my
own voice that was Batgirl Bullwinkle
it's like that classic story the line
and the mouse that we're ripping off
when you're voice acting you have to tap
into the ability to make something
believable without it being there it's a
completely different art form than
on-camera you have to let the audience
feel what it's like to fall off a cliff
without there actually being a cliff
there you gotta have to be willing to
play around and not afraid to look silly
and then once you create a character in
my experience they like live up in my
brain and they're just ready to come
down when it's our turn so I don't
confuse them they all are their own
entity basically I'm a crazy person so I
just need a long scream as you just keep
going
[Music]
we need we need the store garbage bags
oh yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]